so let me start with you ali
um when you got married did you sign up
Arena oh I was supposed to yeah but then
the war in the Ukraine kicked off so he
got really worried and so we kind of
scrambled but I mean yeah I suppose my
husband would be considered to be in a
vulnerable position but I'm ready to
sign anything at any point in time if he
drafts a post-op I've heard something
called the post right I've always been
prepared to sign I don't have a problem
so you can thank Vladimir Putin for not
having to sign a prenup yes I know I
know but I mean I would if he showed up
tomorrow and was like hey babe sign this
Payless yeah yeah straight problem with
it no I mean maybe that's why he hasn't
done it I don't know wow yeah well I
mean if you're think about it if your
man has um anxiety about like finances
and you taking half of stuff which a lot
of women do and you want to be with them
and just sign it because you get to keep
all of the resources if you just stay
married I think it actually keeps a
woman committed if what if she signs a
prenup I think she's got more skin in
the game okay
um now let's do a poll yeah to all our
friends out there who are married or are
planning on getting married I assume
most of you guys are men even women
success
do you how do you feel about a prenup
yes I would want a prenup no I'm good I
don't need to sign a prenup
um I would love to hear that answer Leia
I know you have strong opinions on this
topic I know that you are the uh
extraordinary woman you're not the
ordinary woman so nobody assumes that
you're average so
um what are your thoughts on prenups I
understand why somebody would want a
prenup I think um now this is just my
cynical point of view I think most
people are inherently like selfish and
bad unfortunately and so there are a lot
of women who will definitely marry men
just for their money
um and the man is isn't very interesting
so she'll lose sexual interest in him
cheat on him and then she'll
get a divorce and she'll you know have
the kids and have all his money so I I
understand right
um but I don't know enough about prenups
to understand
um like what kind of nuance there is to
it so an example is if I get married or
when I get married the better term is
when I get married
um you know and if my husband says to me
Leia I don't want you working you don't
need to work because I will provide for
us okay I'm like okay that's that that's
an interesting offer definitely like if
you don't be working because you can
afford both of us then why not okay
um then I won't work fine but now that
leads me in a vulnerable position
because I'm like well what if you know
in 10 20 years time something happens
and you know we're not together anymore
it's like well I've just sacrificed my
my money maker
um you know for this marriage and now
I'm like on the streets and I'm broke
right so I don't know whether there's a
prenup which sort of says you know you
get x amount I don't know but yeah
it's not all or nothing different
Clauses then I think a clause is a new
one so prenup is important because
ultimately if a man says to a woman I
don't want you working and then 10 years
later he just leaves her and she's like
damn I've got nothing that's not fair so
I think yeah Nuance is required well I
think uh 80 of marriage or divorces are
initiated by women yes and the more
educated they are I think
it's a reference shout out to your
friend Pearl right I learned that from
her when she was on here but so
initially gut reaction you don't want to
sign a prenup no I know I I understand
I'm just saying I think Nuance is
required and I our initial conversation
I don't know about what do I know about
prenups you know what I mean I'm never
being mad what do I know but that's the
problem that's the problem is like most
women don't know that they can advocate
for themselves with a prenup and a post
not but I think a lot of men are full on
themselves because they think that they
have a net worth worth getting a prenup
over a prenup is going to cost it's
going to cost you several Grand I'm sure
the more your worth it's gonna cost even
more than that so my husband has a
reason this man spent his you know 20s
30s 40s to have those resources and so
it would make sense to guard that um but
also I would say I think a lot of women
approach marriage with fear because if
like you're talking about it 10 years
later he decides not to well if you're a
good wife and you give them kids and
things like that and for some
uncontrollable reason he ends up wanting
to initiate a divorce like why wouldn't
he take care of you is kind of my
question I would think that he would
you're the mother of his kids you know
you you are correct however I think that
we have to always be careful in life and
like you should always you know think
you never know what could happen
um you always have to be careful like I
work in the Bitcoin space and that's all
about like having a backup plan don't
rely on anyone you know the government
could come and [ __ ] you basically so
like I'm all about just you know
survival and protecting yourself and you
know knowing that you're gonna be okay
Sarah one day you're gonna meet a man
he's gonna sweep you off your feet and
he's gonna ask you to marry him and he's
going to want you to sign a prenup I
think that if the man has worked all
that time and that protects his own
assets like if I put myself in his shoes
you know I I would be like okay I I
would want someone to sign a premium too
it doesn't mean I don't love you it's
like I just work the past x amount of
years I think that's fair I mean I I I'm
with her like I don't really know much
about prenups either but I was telling
her earlier like one of my very dearest
friends she's married she gave him kids
she was a perfect wife and she's an
amazing woman and he's cheating on her
he's gonna leave her and they didn't
sign a prenup so he's trying to like
leave her with nothing and it's like
again I don't know much about prenups
maybe they protect both maybe I I don't
know
you bring up a perfect point if at any
point in the relationship the woman
checks out cheats you know wants to move
on and she there's no prenup she can
take that dude for all these [ __ ]
worth assuming that he's making the
money okay or I won't say all I'll say
half I have plenty of successful guys in
my life older than me that have been
married for x amount of years they're
paying their women stupid money now
granted they had kids with these women
and there's you know there's a fair
balanced approach to it I get it they
ain't happy paying 10 grand a month to
the X I can guarantee you that at the
same time I can completely empathize
with a woman's perspective where she's
like look
like what Leia said you want me to give
up my career raise the kids and you know
dedicate my life to being a housewife or
just being a mother which we're happy to
do what you're happy to do but you want
to go start [ __ ] the maid and like
now I'm stuck like Chuck and I got a no
prenup so the point is this
I see both sides of the equation
most relationships this is a very
uncomfortable conversation to have but
if you just read the stats right what
percentages of marriages last uh 41 of
marriages end in divorce flip a coin
whether your marriage works or not 60 of
a second marriages even more 73 of third
marriages based on numbers you're going
to want to protect yourself from a man
or a woman that's my friend a lot of
girls look to get married to get that
possible
yeah exactly it's
with girls and I've heard them talk
about this and I think that's gross I
mean marry someone you love or don't get
married like don't get married let me
tell you something I'm not gonna name
names I haven't been naming names this
whole show but I had a very
uncomfortable conversation with uh let's
just say a girl I know who was doing
maybe not so nice things to in their
relationship and I said let me tell you
something uh if I'm that dude
your ass is out the [ __ ] door Peace
what's she doing can't really explain
that but just understand that she broke
some rules and I said if I'm that dude
pack your [ __ ] up [ __ ] and I straight
up said this to her face and she goes
well you know what sometimes it's
cheaper to keep her I said and I go and
that is why I'll have a [ __ ] prenup
okay because I've spent my last 20
something years working to become a
millionaire and have money in the bank
and that type of attitude
yeah that'll do it for me so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]